there was more spanish people at the
games and latin people at the games
tenfold since i've been there like and i
would see them and they would marie
i was like bro i'm trying to play like
you can't be yelling
there was a point where i was just
answering spanish questions
and i'm like looking at the giant staff
like come get me okay
this is the sixth maintenance question
i'm running out of spanish adjectives
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today
victor cruz what's good with you man i'm
good man no complaints
are you good at pool at all oh yeah bro
i'm nice man yeah everybody always want
to check me on this man i'm nice man
i'm gonna check you i'm nice and pulled
just like you nice in pre-season games
okay you know what i'm saying that's how
we doing it
okay a little pop on it a little
something i'ma offset that convo by
saying this
for some damn reason you had me in the
crib salsa dancing everybody in a mama
salsa dancing in your career yeah how
did that start
man the salsa dance started it was 2011.
the year we won the super bowl so
backstory i'm half puerto rican
grew up in the puerto rico shout out to
the latinx football shout out to
everybody out there in latinx community
all day you have to that being in my
blood my grandmother just taught me
every dance in the book growing up you
know what i'm saying bachata man
gets outside we was in the living room
doing it all and i hated it at 10 years
old
but she's like why don't you hate it
because it's like nobody as a 10 year
old you're not trying to be embarrassed
dancing with your grandmother in the
living room you know what i'm saying
like you're just
you're embarrassed you know i had
friends over she didn't care we'd still
be dancing and i'm embarrassed
so it was that part of it i remember her
telling me every single time like
when you get older you're gonna
appreciate this moment you're gonna love
me
fast forward one of my coaches named
mike sullivan came up to me and was like
yo you starting this week
you got to represent your culture and
your heritage and do something in the
end zone all week he was bugging me
bugging me
i told him i'd do it so you can get out
of my face right as a kid right you just
think about
what's gonna be your thing in the end
zone you know about like steve smith and
when i was younger and like watching him
play
and him like rowing the boat in the end
zone and just doing different things
and then the game came around it was my
first catch of the game and i shake two
dudes off and i'm up the sideline for
like a 74 yard touchdown
and i vividly remember in my head at
like the three yard line as i'm walking
in
like i gotta do this dance now i cannot
do it now the philly fans are booing me
in the corner of the end zone and i just
started dancing the sausage just came to
me
and my grandmother actually ended up and
before she passed away she actually
watched one of the games so she calls me
and was like what was that
and i was like well i did a little salsa
for you i think you
would be proud you taught me how to do
it and she was like from now on as long
as you play in the league
your celebratory dance has to be the
salsa dance and i was like
done wow easy who is the most famous
person that busted out the sauce in
front of you
oh man had to be barack obama remember
yeah it was cool
[Music]
i mean real one's called mobizi yeah you
already know we got to call him
obviously
while he was in the oval office while he
was the president man and it was crazy
i went to like a fundraiser and he sees
me out the corner of his eye
and as he's talking to them he kind of
like does one of these he's right
and i'm bugging i'm just like standing
there like yo he's really
is mark anthony behind me because he
could be he could be doing it for him
but he's doing it for me and then i walk
up and he's like yeah man i'm a big fan
of what you got going i'm a fan of the
dances i'm a fan of football
i remember the jitters that i got from
just being in that room and seeing him
there having that interaction you know
you don't get that
interaction often and the first black
president he changed the game
for me for a lot of people i'm sure so
for me to have that opportunity to be
there with him and for him to break out
the salsa and it was pretty good too
wasn't bad the crazy part is you talk
about how much significance the dance
has for you people trying to mock you
yeah you're trying to trying to do the
dance too right
yeah i remember 2011. we played the
49ers and carlos rogers
got an interception against me and got
up and started doing the salsa dance
then they just asked me how i felt about
it
and i gave my honest opinion and i was
just saying how you know
it's a special thing for me with my
grandmother her showing me how to dance
and her passing away that very year
it ended up being even more special to
me because of the timing of it all
carlos rodgers caught wind of that story
and he apologized later for doing it
you know he was a good dude and all the
rivalries we've had he's always been a
real one we've always spoken after the
games and just had that mutual respect
for one another
okay i will say once you had your
injuries the two years that you were
absent
we weren't able to see the salsa dancing
on the field what were those two years
like for you those are some of the
roughest years in my life to be honest
because you know you sit there and
a part of your life is kind of taken
away from you in a sense when you're
injured you don't want to go anywhere
you're just up
beer growing all kind of hair on my face
i even know it could grow there in
certain areas
my family was like yo let's go even if
they put me in the car and we rode
around for an hour somewhere like they
just wanted to get me out of the house
get some fresh air at times i don't even
know if my family knows that but those
moments in those times really went a
long way
there it is two years you were out you
were able to come back
and we did get to see the salsa dance
one more time
what was that moment like when you able
to score i think it was all my cowboys
too right it was indeed on your cowboys
i'm looking to look right at the camera
and say that it was on his cowboy
that moment man the game-winning
touchdown and like the salsa and i got
this
crazy photo in my crib of odell when he
took the photo of me doing the salsa
dance it's like an iconic photo at this
point just that feeling of finally
breaking through man and finally getting
back on that field
and after so many ups and downs and so
many surgeries and
a million mris a winning culture here at
the giants you know so
the fact that they gave me that
opportunity to rehab and get back out
there and still
make an impact on the team throughout
that year it was special i mean you've
won a super bowl
you've had your own nike shoe where does
that touchdown rank in terms of your
career highlight moments
it's up there it's like number three or
four one is like my daughter being born
right before the super bowl and then
winning the super bowl is another
and then that comeback was like gotta be
right there for me to come back from
that when everybody probably counted me
out whenever i thought i couldn't come
back when everybody was
waiting anticipation to see what type of
athlete i was to come back
score the game winning touchdown and
just have my whole team excited for me
on the way back home
it was pretty special when you look at
your career the salsa dance
10 years old you dancing with your
grandma and now it being
a symbolic gesture symbolic dance for
you in your career
what does the salsa dance mean to you
now it probably means more to me now
you know as you get older and you have
children of your own like you understand
the sacrifices that your grandparents
made and your parents made
for you so for me to honor my
grandmother who made the ultimate
sacrifices coming here from puerto rico
with my mom it embodies so much more
than just a dance it brings me back to
the memories of when we lived in a
tiny apartment and were dancing on the
floor but the tiny apartment felt like a
mansion to me as a kid and i know it'd
be special to the fans because
they don't care where i'm at they asked
me to dance for them in public
so that's a thing that actually happens
over under how many times have you
danced for someone
i mean do you have time do we have
enough time in the segment
i mean just yesterday i was out just
yesterday just yesterday i was in the
grocery store i won't say the name
because people will start
flocking there i'm walking out and like
you can tell someone kind of beat it out
must have asked someone if that was me
and then ran outside
and he asked me for a photo and i kind
of gave him like the social distance
photo all right kind of lean
and then he goes man can we see it can
we see that then i'm like see
my id what are you talking about don't
make me dance here i was like only if
you dance with me
i'm gonna be embarrassed you're gonna be
ambassador and he just started dancing
and i was like damn i gotta do this with
you now let me do it
but i like to have fun with it now you
know i'm not good i'd rather just not be
dancing for your enjoyment if i'm gonna
be embarrassed you're gonna be
embarrassed yeah we're gonna do it
together
yeah you ain't laughing at me we might
be getting this party we're gonna do it
bang bang